I've got Kirsten on the line calling me
from Tucson Kirsten how are you I'm
doing okay how are you I'm focused and
not finish young lady what's on your
mind
well I had a question I have a parent
who's incarcerated and it's been a
situation that's been going on for a
couple years she's almost done because
of all of these reductions that have
being passed through Congress is gonna
get out in about a year
I'm suppose I just sent her a copy of
the Total Money Makeover for herself
because she did have debt before she
went in and we're trying to get her to
where when she comes out she's able to
be integrated back into society yes
she's very close to finishing her degree
with an electrician work so before I
moved to Tucson I made about $80,000 a
year and I took a year off and moved to
Tucson and I only make about 22,000 now
I end her money every week and it's a
little bit of a strain on my budget and
I just don't I just want to know morally
if you think that it's a oh sorry I
think it was gonna get emotional um I
just want to know if you think it's a
good idea investing in her in this way
because I mean I want her to be
successful and to the thalamus and I
know that she'll help me back when she
gets out and we'll be in a much better
situation but at the moment I just feel
it bearing on me a lot Kirsten ticket
breath young lady this is uh this is a
real scenario and are you an only child
how many siblings do you have
okay Wow big family and so your mom has
has been incarcerated how long most of
my life she only has three children died
I have family with my parent other
parents okay okay well how old are you
I'm 26 so most of your life she's been
in and out yes okay how much money are
you sending each week um I used to send
her $50 a week
now I've been telling something that I
really can't and I think it's like you
know it's $20 when I can so it's when I
have X erm in the budget but it takes
away from my debt snowball so I feel a
little some kind of way about it
yeah no I understand do you have any
kids
I don't okay and right now talk to me
about your debt what do you owe on I
only have a thousand website on my car
so I'm almost done thing that off and I
include I include all of my currents
that's so like the rest of my lease on
my rent and like I have a cell phone
with a PNP that I still can and so with
all of my debts hold a lot of 14,000
left which I started my debt snowball
two years ago with 80,000 yes
so right now you owe a thousand on a car
how much in medical bills do you have
right now it's a variable amount I mean
it's a part that I'm paying on I only
have 5 mm left but I just had I just had
an ER so that might be about 5,000 but
I'm settling that was insurance that I'm
not counting that and my total debt yet
because it has been assigned to me all
right now you mentioned also that your
income had been around 85,000 but now
it's 2022 what were you doing before you
moved and I did really well there it's
just that I worked there for five years
and it was very stressful and I never
thought to build a life on myself no I
understand well I this is a tough spot
right I mean anytime you have a parent
going through a situation like this I
think you looking at your budget and
figuring out what you can afford to do I
don't think that there's a problem you
sending you know $20 when you can send
it I don't think you need to feel the
stress of the pressure to do more and
you know if you were telling me that
your your mother was trying to guilt you
into sending money then that's another
boundary you know that we'd have to look
at but and as far as you being able I
like
you've stood up for yourself that you're
sending in what you can and and again
looking at it real thinking
realistically what's this money being
used for it right I mean we have to be
honest about that because the you know
housing and meals and all that's taken
care of so what is it about I like that
you sent her Total Money Makeover and
you're right that she's also trying to
help herself
pursuing kind of the electrician things
so when she comes out hopefully she can
stay out and begin to do right what what
she needs to do for herself so I think
you praying for your mom you being there
and sending what you can is a good thing
but you're right you've got your own
stuff that you're trying to clean up
here and so again you know just like I
would tell a parent if they were dealing
with a child right or an adult young
adult that you know it's not the parents
job to do everything for that young
adult that young adult at some point has
to work and start to be productive but
you can help them and giving tools the
books and information like that is a way
to be able to help and I think that's
okay but you stick to your budget and
you stick to your plan and if you're not
able to and you don't have it then you
communicate that right and that's what
you do you don't feel unnecessary stress
or pressure you just want to communicate
it and let her know so everyone's on the
same page and I like the path that
you're on
you you've had to grow up well beyond
your years at 26 years old and I like
what the path that you're on and I want
you to continue down that road and make
sure you get people around you right
make sure you're plugged in to a local
church or some community groups you know
where you've got an opportunity to have
people that are supporting and cheering
for you as well